well well well reject
nation i was out of town this weekend
and never
ever in my entire time have i
ever gotten so many requests to check
out a cosmic
wonder video this came out a few days
ago
it won't stop it won't stop people
constantly keep telling us this is not a
joke because there's no hyperbole here
there's nothing i'm fainting
spiderman no way home full movie
description leak this
is highly requested so
warren i know you're at least peeking at
this video and yeah bud you pulled this
off he's been upping his editing game
putting a lot of work and he was
actually texting me the day he was
editing this going like
60 minute video is a lot to edit right
now i'm glad to see how well it's taking
off and i have
literally never seen so many people be
like this sounds legit you gotta check
it out
so many comments yeah let's see what all
the buzz is about
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have
a spider-man plot leak that a lot of
people have sent me and it is the most
detailed plot leak that i have ever seen
since doing youtube now this caught my
attention because as i mentioned
a few videos ago a couple of insiders
have told me about
a few plot details that are confirmed to
be true
coming up in spider-man no way home i
did a video on what those are i shared
them with you and you can find those
actually in this plot leak but in this
plot leak sense they're actually tied
into the story
now of course with all plot leaks we
take them with a grain of salt but like
i just said
there are some points in this plot leak
that i know are confirmed to be true
now this was posted online apparently by
somebody who works at marvel studios
they claim that they haven't actually
seen the movie but they have
read the script and they say they posted
this they have lost their job
waiting and i think we're all tired of
waiting and if that is true
that kind of indicates that it's sony's
fault to blame for us not getting the
trailer yet which
i kind of think everybody figured
anyways so like i said it's insanely
detailed it's incredibly long so we're
just gonna dive into it it sounds very
awesome i'm tired of waiting
for the weirder thing he's tired in
there that i can confirm
and if you like plot leaks and keeping
up to date with the mcu be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
all right this is divided into three
acts and i'm just going to
say the whole thing it's like a script
i'll talk about it
the first scene takes place in an
abandoned building somewhere in new york
at night
a group of teenagers is exploring this
abandoned building for a live stream
they're doing
they talk about how the place is
supposedly haunted they eventually
encounter a mysterious figure stumbling
out of the darkness
cladding green armor but injured the
teenagers are scared but they attempt to
mock the figure but they run as soon
as the figure starts walking towards
them the figure is none other than
willem dafoe's green goblin wearing his
armor from the 2002 spider-man movie
but without the helmet an extended
version of the breaking news
then we see a montage of screens
broadcasting the same video we saw at
the ending of far from home when
mysterio exposes peter parker as
spider-man and of course
jk simmons's new version of jay jonah
jameson
spider-man is holding his head in panic
just as he was at the end of far from
home
he looks back at mj and then back at the
screen we then see the reactions of
various people we see flash thompson
drop a snack from his mouth as he's
watching
surprised at the fact that peter parker
is spider-man ned is with his mother
just as shocked spider-man swings away
as people look at him telling mj to meet
him back at queens aunt may frantically
calls him about what's happening
spidey tells her that he'll be home soon
and that they should move away as he
fears there might be a mob that will
attack their home
peter arrives at their apartment
building in queens and they talk about
what to do
calling happy obviously aunt may ned and
mj know that peter is innocent
they also attempt to contact nick fury
but he doesn't answer because he's in
space then there's a joke about nick
ghosting peter back for not answering
his calls and far from home
peter tells us that he may have joked
things down since peter parker was just
a normal teenager so not many people
will know where he lives anyway
but then they just suddenly hear a bunch
of people gathered outside
yelling at them including brad davis and
a few other students from brad davison
who probably led the mob to his home
happy attempts to pick peter and mae up
from their apartment but the people in
front of the apartment building are
getting in his way
peter sees happy outside the window
gesturing for them to get back down
peter quickly changes to his civilian
outfit goes back down with may and
confronts the mob pretending to not know
what the hell is happening
brad davis calls him out that he should
know what's happening since his face was
just broadcast all
over the world happy comes out of his
car and escorts them to the car
inside the car they discuss what to do
happy suggests hiring a lawyer so they
can settle this legally as there's
really nothing else they can do at this
point
mae says she might know someone she
pulls out her phone and starts
contacting a lawyer we cut to a
courthouse
peter is on trial the lawyer is none
other than matt murdock played by
charlie cox
the witness is one of mysterio's
accomplices the court battle gets heated
as the accomplice presents new evidence
showing a more
convincing footage of peter killing
mysterio that was not shown to the
public
it's a video that was edited to make it
look like peter shot mysterio at point
blank
they also mentioned that the video has
been examined for any sign of fakery
but none was found matt attempts to
speak back but he was cut off by the
judge and branded guilty
matt tells peter that he'll find a way
to fix this because he knows that peter
is innocent but also subtly implies that
he knows he's also spider-man
this is the last that we see of matt
murdock peter is arrested and he tells
aunt may that he has no choice but to
serve a sentence and assures her that
he'll be fine
we see a shot of peter in a police car
looking out to the crowd as people yell
spider-man is a murderer
peter spends a day in prison being
bullied by other inmates but he wouldn't
fight back
in his cell a tiny portal opens in front
of him and a piece of paper comes out of
it
the paper reads 177a bleaker street
hurry and we've definitely seen that
before but peter escapes through the
bard window by breaking the bars and
crawling out okay
so far i'm liking it i haven't gone into
full believable
territory yet i'm not gonna say i
believe it just yet obviously we're so
early in
idea of kicking off here with green
goblin is a cool tease for what's to
come
that he's already there right like he's
already transported over there
it's taking place after multiverse
events of loki and whatnot for him to
really be
like it's called no way home and to have
this real fugitive style to it where he
has to break out of jail go to bleecker
street go to see doctor strange that
sounds cool
uh but i don't know i'm just i'm really
hesitant
really cautious on this absolutely
considering how descriptive it is and
the thing that started me off honestly
it's just the first thing i'm saying
of someone working at marvel saying i'm
tired of waiting like what what
individual would be there
doing that that's the most suspicious
thing i've heard not even the plot leak
it's just that that's with access yeah
with enough clout and and status at
marvel to have access to information
like this would be also in a position to
be like ugh
i don't just don't want to wait i'll
jeopardize my entire well-being and my
life
that's what i mean that's the most
suspicious part to me about it and
because it's so detailed it's easy to
believe it ned and mj are at may's house
to accompany her so that she wouldn't be
lonely peter comes in through the window
may ned and mj are surprised and happy
that peter escaped but also concerned as
that would ruin his reputation even
further
peter tells them that doctor strange is
calling for him and he'll be going there
ned and mj asked to go with him he
disagrees but eventually they all go
together
they arrive and look around at the place
and they look up to see dr strange
dramatically floating down the stairs
and this is the picture that was
officially released where tom zendaya
and jacob are looking up
he leads them to a room with an orb in
the middle with vein like trails all
over the area
he explains that the flow of time has
somehow been disturbed in that many
realities are starting to bleed into
each
other and obviously with loki we know
this to be true strange tells peter that
two timelines are merging into their own
but with the orb that he apparently dug
up from somewhere it has the ability to
slow down the merging process
peter asked strange why he called on him
and not somebody else and strange says
that he is somehow the center of the
current problem he's dealing with a
problem that's part of an even bigger
problem
strain says that he can't leave the
sanctum because he has to keep reality
stable
and this is very difficult now as all
the infinity stones have been destroyed
so he has to rely on pure magic
it is from here that strange starts to
warn peter about the villains and he
reveals that the villains are taken from
various points of the timeline of the
tobey maguire and andrew garfield movies
as timelines
to make sure that peter is up for the
task strange teleports peter's iron
spider suit to the sanctum and combines
it with magic
turning it into an integrated suit he
tells peter that it'll allow him to use
magic that will allow him to put the
villains in stasis and put them back
into the sanctum so strange can bring
them back to their respective universes
and timelines so it's kind of like
far from home in this sense of how it
starts off and there's already villains
there like yes
uh the elementals are all fake they're
all illusions
let's take out the whole thing with
illusion make it actual physical
reality and that's kind of the setup
that's happening
here yeah according to this plot leak
trouble's already a foot
that like goblins here the other
villains are already here and versus
bleeding
the way how spidey was recruited to help
take care of the problem
it sounds like a repeat plot beat of far
from home that's just like the vibe i'm
picking up on right now
and peter actually ends up capturing the
villains and bringing them back to the
sanctum but peter was injured fighting
doc ock
while recovering peter talks to sandman
and learns that back in his reality
his daughter penny is sick and that he's
only been doing everything he can to
save her
wait a minute peter got them here's
something i'm not really liking about
what i'm hearing
peter getting a special suit having some
magic equipped with it based off the set
of circumstances of the stakes
sure that makes sense to me but it seems
so early on into act two and then all
these villains are gonna come in at the
beginning of act two and then peter
just using some newly learned magic with
this dude
is able to take all the villains on
contain them it seems like okay that's
really lucky on peter's end and b
it undercuts the the stakes of the
villains
yeah if you were to do that so early on
which is making me have a hard time
believing
because then it's also like how did they
then get back out that one leak about
like ah peter just like gets sympathetic
and decides to let them out
this is true i'm like but you just spent
all this time and effort like catching
them and if you just got mangled up a
bit by doc ock
but that might not be in this leak that
we're talking about here that's fair
you're bringing another leak into here
there are just so many
leaks they're not all leaks no trailers
i'm just saying from a storytelling
point of view
that's having me a heart hey i'm like if
that actually happens i feel like that
kind of undercuts the weight of the
situation and
b that's making me have a harder time
actually wrapping my head around it
because i feel like that's weights
if you're supposed to build these
villains up right theoretically it seems
to
increase the stakes of how hard it is to
take them on yeah to take them out so
early on
at least contain them you know it makes
it less exciting
yeah you could make an entire movie out
of containing them the first time
peter recognizes the name and asks him
if her last name is marco to which he
says
yes peter tells him that he knows a girl
named penny marco in his school
who was happy and was the survivor of
sickness and that her father flint
died during a bank robbery in an attempt
to get money to save her
he reveals that his name is also flint
and sheds a tear
peter then asks him what in his world is
like
that he only fought him once inside an
armored vehicle
wait a minute okay only fun of what's
that armored vehicle is not factual so
it's the idea that sandman is pulled out
early on
might be like halfway through spider-man
3. so because he fought him again in the
finale
exactly and it's not at the moment just
before being vanquished or whatever
yeah you know with this leak it's saying
that sandman did not have his whole
character already yes apparently yeah
apparently so may ends up at the sanctum
as well and ned
mj peter and her spend the night there
suddenly they hear an explosion where
the villains are imprisoned
peter rushes back to where the villains
are and found that most of them have
escaped except for sandman who looks at
him and says sorry before disappearing
strange was caught off guard and injured
by the explosion and says that the event
has worsened the reality state
strange tells peter not to go after them
while injured but of course peter
puts on the integrated suit and he goes
and leaves he ends up fighting them all
except for sandman who is really trying
his best not to hurt him but the other
villains try and kill him spider-man
ends up crashing into a rooftop
completely battered more than he ever
was before then a figure in green armor
and a purple hoodie approaches him he
takes off his hood revealing him to be
norman osborne of the sam raimi universe
and here's where things actually start
to get pretty intense we find out that
he was taken from the sam raimi universe
right before the glider ran into him and
killed him but he was actually sent to
the past of the mcu
the main sacred timeline from there he
actually murdered the current norman
osborne preventing oscorp from existing
in the mcu
instead of turning oscorp into a big
name he instead waited for the right
time to strike
at first he thought the mcu didn't have
a spider-man but later found out about
his existence because of the events of
homecoming and far from home
norman prepares to kill him as he has
learned his lesson not to let spider-man
live and get in his way but right before
he goes to kill him
spider-man is saved by none other than
andrew garfield spider-man he grabs him
and takes him back to the sanctum and
apparently that's the end of act one and
now we go into act two
that's act one i don't believe this
that's it
you're way into it like a whole movie
the second you said that cnn acts when i
was like
nope don't buy it like a half hour don't
buy it
how long is any scene gonna get to be
active one is
at most 30 minutes there's no way
there's unless this movie is like three
hours three and a half maybe this will
be the first time every afternoon
but still like that is so much to do
with that i thought we were
halfway through activities yeah i was
gonna say it's like you've had all the
villains captured and then they all
escape he has time to have an exchange
with samuel
sandman sorry but then andrew garfield's
here i'm enjoying parts of it i like the
idea of how norman osborn is actually
william defoe has been here for a while
living i mean i don't know what took him
so long to finally emerge well and you
know if you kill your oz corp legacy
it's going to be hard to get money in a
new universe because
but there are things about it that are
not lining up quite right to me because
the events of loki the multiverse you
know branching off and all that they're
saying he's been here for a while so
like the timeline of the mcu the sacred
timeline that we
as audi timbers are invested in has been
rewritten slightly
to where this norman osborne has been
living in the sacred timeline
yes that's what's being said here yeah
yeah i don't know what took him so long
in addition to whatever other norman we
never see
because he killed him just waiting for
the right time to emerge now there's a
spider-man i should emerge
and be the savior it's a weird there's a
weird video for us to do because some
people requested it and we're honest if
we believe a leak or not yeah
and i'm like i think everyone wants us
to believe this
everyone there's just a lot of things
i'm not buying about it everyone wants
the movie
don't let it don't let that persuade you
on yeah
not a bad idea i don't know when we get
a trailer we'll see if any of this lines
up back at the sanctum
ned mj and aunt may are surprised to see
another spider-man carrying peter
we find out that andrew spider-man has
actually been in the mcu for a few
months and doctor strange says that he
used a
forgotten spell that's able to pull
people from other universes
into the mcu while the breech can do
this as well by random
his spell allows him to specifically
choose people to bring over and he chose
to bring over andrew spider-man for help
meanwhile the sinister six have formed
and they now have a base
sandman wants to actually go back to his
universe but the others state that they
die in their own universes and no longer
have a purpose there they're going to
attack the sanctum
kill strange both spider-man and take
the orb however strange finds this out
as he was spying on them
via astral projection back at the
sanctum the group asks andrew spider-man
a bunch of questions
ned states that they don't look anything
alike but of course we know that they
don't have to because of the loki series
the two of them start to bond and peter
tells the other peter how he went to
space
but then mid-conversation they are
interrupted by strange returning to the
sanctum telling them that they need to
prepare for an attack
strange says that'll help as much as he
can but he can't give spider-man any
more of his magic
from here peter calls happy telling him
that they need better suits
happy heads over to the sanctum but
meanwhile spider-man's reputation is
further damaged after his escape from
prison
and in school flash is actually the one
being bullied for supporting spider-man
happy gets to this fallen get new suits
tom holland spider-man rocking the black
and gold one that we've seen
i love the idea of just them cutting
back to the high school red
chicken
all our favorite characters from school
see how the one funny teacher is doing
all those guys martin starr
and happy i need a better suit now mj
and peter have a moment and they share a
kiss
we then cut to new york city at sunset
we see a young woman being mugged by a
thug played by harry holland
tom holland's brother but the thug is
webbed up by toby maguire spider-man
toby asks if she's okay and then takes a
break at a rooftop nearby he takes off
his mask and then he gets a call from
kristen dunce's mj
it cuts to their living room where she
is caring for their daughter named
may parker they start talking about
toby's decision of retiring as
spider-man as other heroes are now
appearing
in his world toby arrives home plays
with his daughter and then talks with mj
about how he needs to be there more for
his daughter i'm so confused
are we in our timeline i think or do we
hop
over to the rainy verse because they're
just saying that toby's just like i'm
checking up on my wife and daughter yeah
yeah wait so you guys were put over here
too you just settled in and now you're
just deciding to come out
that's the only way it would make sense
to me and i guess maybe the hairy
holland it just exists in that universe
and is there to confuse us or something
kind of sound like how
in civil war where you're like close to
the
finale when they just cut to peter
parker in queens
yeah and then iron man's visiting him so
you're like kind of cutting away from
the main story
to go introduce this other spider-man
character yeah but it's not on this
earth
yeah i mean if toby maguire's spider-man
shows up then yeah it has to be in the
sam raimi verse
okay so we're cutting to that verse all
right but my question
becomes we've seen set photos of harry
holland and
tom holland in the suit yes so i don't
just like the photo that was shown here
yeah just like literally that one that's
one job my memory yeah and that also
that's another point to just try on me
to describe
we didn't want to come here well that's
the same they're pointing out things
that are like making us not believe it
it's funny i think that when the leaks
are smaller it's almost a bit more like
oh yeah it's just
one little detail so it could be
plausible whereas when you hear them all
together it at least instills within me
a more of a drive to be very critical
and analytical and like really zero in
on
well there was one link we heard that we
really believed and there's been a
couple that we haven't
yes it's kind of falling in that
category for all the reasons we're
saying
he promises to take it easy now and we
also see a newspaper that seemingly
implies that the events of the canceled
spider-man 4 movie
actually happened in the universe
that would be cool they should do that
yes
knowing that strange is expecting him he
talks about how this new world
is his chance to be bigger than he was
in his other universe
the sinister six start attacking the
sanctum but it is seemingly empty
then tom holland's peter parker jumps
out of a dark spot and kicks elektro in
the head
then the two spider-man start to fight
the sinister six andrew has a rematch
against the lizard but doctor strange
ends up getting knocked unconscious due
to him being weakened from trying to
bind reality from breaking
this is a huge fight and it ends up with
both the spider-man injured but they
were able to subdue
lizard scorpion vulture and dock tom
attempts to capture norman but norman
catches him off guard and stabs him with
a blade through the shoulder
however sandman betrays norman and
attacks him sandman is then killed after
norman detonated what seems to be a
pumpkin bomb
filled with fluid as it turned out
norman had a contingency plan in case
the other villains tried to betray him
tom tries to attack him again but then
norman summons a new glider
both the spider-man put up a fight but
ultimately they are no match against him
with both spider-man knocked down and
almost knocked down for good
mj attacks norman osborne with a metal
pipe what exactly is making this green
goblin
so superior i'm not sure because again
if
spider-man can't take him on because
especially if he's been living in our
world
and he doesn't have any oz corp style
resources
like he must be just like a vagrant
that's like me i'm not i'm not saying it
as like a criticism to add disbelief i'm
saying
that like i've got i've lost a bit on
how he's so strong unless he's just done
that this whole time he's just like
strength
training and then martial arts training
and nothing else
but it doesn't hurt him and he turns to
her grabs her by the neck and throws her
across the room
tom screams but is knocked down by
norman with one
punch norman then goes to the room where
strange's body is
and the two of them have a conversation
and norman tells strange that he spent
too much time on trying to maintain
reality
that has been severely weakened norman
goes for the kill but strange lets go of
the orb and fights norman but not before
doing a brief spell on the orb that
makes it glow red briefly
norman is no match against strange but
elektro then appears and takes the orb
while strange is distracted
strange attempts to cast a portal in
front of elektro as he escapes but
norman grabs strange and throws him
against a wall
when strange gets back up norman and
electro have disappeared
tom cradles mj who is severely bleeding
mirroring the scene where andrew lost
gwen in the amazing spider-man 2.
suggesting mj's gonna die
shock and mj dies
but strange tells them that they've
escaped with the orb however strange has
brought in
one last backup even though it isn't
much andrew's spider-man tells peter how
he lost gwen in his own universe
then peter shares how he lost tony stark
they then talk about how being
spider-man
will always lead to suffering they must
persevere
[Music]
while the stakes of that would be very
unexpected to say
after the death of mj i lost gwen i lost
today
and now mj as well i don't think that's
gonna happen
i think that'll i don't think they're
gonna kill off freaking zendaya i know
they're gonna do that
yeah and what has she gotten to do
across this movie except
like you know be happy except worried
that peter got out of jail have a kiss
with him at one point after showing up
at the sanctum and now dying
i like the idea of andrew garfield
if his gwen is dead of having ability
to for tom holland to confide in him
maybe you get some dialogue that
represents some type of catharsis
for andrew garfield since she died in
amazing spider-man 2
then the movie ended like 10 minutes
later
to see what his growth is uh i i i don't
think they would i just i don't believe
they would be ballsy and i would kind of
be down for it just because of the move
to do it yeah i'd be down for it yeah so
i'm not against it i just don't
buy that they actually would kill a off
i don't buy the
the way it's presented here back in the
reemi universe toby's spider-man
is telling a speech to his daughter
about how he'll think she'll grow up to
be somebody wonderful but then a portal
opens up behind him and mary jane also
walks into the room
the final fight is against the sinister
six and the three spider-man
the fight ends up he just goes and
fights
deer universes but all three spider-man
gang up on him the other two spider-man
attempt to hold back the sinister six
while tom's spider-man attempts to use
the orb to bring everybody back to their
respective timelines
however norman osborne has been
tinkering with it and has damaged it
because it's overloaded with energy
and using it risks destroying it portals
start to appear in the sky
buildings cars and even people start
falling from them
that would be cool timelines
norman is put back in the last second
before he's impaled my stature liberty
luckily the orb didn't break but it's
heavily cracked
peter then thinks about using the orb to
bring mj back to
wait a minute did i just hear that
correctly this is saying
this is like to say that
put goblin back a second before he's
impaled by the colliders
there's a blink and then current norman
plops back in just in time to get
impaled in the nash and then
it's a fun fanfiction is what this
sounds like there's some exciting stuff
in here but
this is really like questionable and
goofy stuff i can't see any context on
how that
is like could it be awesome well and i
yeah i can't see that not
kind of coming across as like a nelson
muntz like a haha
just like dropping in right at the right
moment just to die peter then thinks
about using the orb to bring
mj back to life and get his secret
identity back strange warns him not to
do that but tom doesn't listen
and he does it anyways the orb then
breaks and peter looks around
as something has happened similar to
when thanos snapped his fingers
doctor strange asks what have you done
and the screen fades to white
we cut to tom in his bed he greets aunt
may good morning and heads to school
at school he sees ned and they see mj
walk past the hallway but she doesn't
recognize them
she also seems more popular than before
peter sees her and becomes sad seeing
her but ned doesn't he just says that
she's out of their league
then tom walks out of a classroom after
class and bumps into a blonde girl they
say sorry to each other and make eye
contact
cut to black while we hear tom ask what
the girl's name is and the movie ends
now as you can see this is just
absolutely
insane and it does actually sound like
what the movie could be
but you'll have to let me know your
thoughts on this i definitely hate the
ending i don't like that
mj dies and then all of a sudden the mcu
is altered to where mj
doesn't know who peter is but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you like this do
you not like this do you think this
could be real
let me know your thoughts i think the
same things that are like isolated stuff
like toby and andrew being in here and
doctor straight
all that overall i do not think this is
how the movie's gonna play out like
i can't see it no i mean i can see it
but
it just sounds like a mess it sounds
like a mess of their things here
i'm like there's no way like there's too
much there's too much in here
yeah and and with all that's been made
out of the idea of including toby
maguire and andrew garfield like
it almost strikes me as strange that you
would have like a side
other movie in the middle of this movie
about tobey maguire
until the very end when he finally like
joins the actual yeah
yeah there are a lot of interesting
concepts here but as like
pitching this is the entire movie it
seems just like way way
too much this seems like a fun
fanfiction
idea ultimately you know we've talked
about that the whole reaction
it it sounds uh too clustered there
would be no flow to it
structurally it just doesn't make sense
to me in a lot of ways it's
right when you said that was act one i
was like no that's not real
that's way too much mark my words i
guarantee you this is not real you could
hold me accountable i know a lot of
people are really into this specific
plot
a lot of people are really loving this
one and this is the most requested but
i'm here to tell you that when you've
watched the first 30 minutes of the new
spider-man no way home movie you'll be
like
that's not at all yeah i mean you might
see daredevil he might have chord stuff
i just don't i'm just saying
it's not going to play out like this
especially with the pacing it's just
like if you you're cutting to
so many of these multiversal like
exploitable elements
as of this leak it feels like a movie
not very much concerned with the actual
character journey of peter
no not at all and mj and ned and like
all the other characters we've come to
know and so yeah like with all these
cool
events and ideas i'm like where would we
ever have time to have like a
a journey for any of them but you guys
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and hey
we'll catch you guys soon and thank you
ward i will say warren your editing has
just
gone so much better absolutely dude much
more engaging video with the way your
visuals are all done thank you for
all the hard work you've done and uh i'm
not crapping on your leak you're just
reading someone else's liking so
thank you for bringing it to me but you
made a good video out of it
thank you buddy
you